Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
damas y caballeros Bienvenidos a este
programa especial que les presentamos
desde el circo Fénix de París sede del
festival más prestigioso del mundo para
las artes circenses pero también los
llevaremos a la Meca de la historieta
Así que quédense con nosotros en
Carrusel de las Artes
[Música]
la ciudad de angulema se sumerge en el
universo del cómic durante su famosísimo
Festival Internacional de la historieta
la edición número 50 rindió homenaje a
los animes japoneses Y en especial al ya
mítico Ataque a los titanes el Mundial
del circo del mañana regresa Después de
tres años de anulaciones espectáculo y
competencia excepcional que reúne a los
mejores artistas jóvenes del mundo
entero y entre los 24 números de magia
malabarismo y acrobacia varios artistas
de México Argentina Uruguay España
quienes conversaron con nosotros
[Música]
hoy en nuestro programa les proponemos
hablarles de dos géneros artísticos muy
populares en Francia el primero es la
historieta Land de cine La bd o cómic
que puede jactarse de tener su propio
Festival Internacional Así que les
proponemos hacer un viaje a la ciudad de
angulema en el sur de Francia para
conocer este festival de la mano de
Melissa barra
[Música]
centenares de aficionados recorren los
pasillos de manga City en busca de
Novedades o de sus autores favoritos
también llamados mangaka pero en
angulema este año las estrellas que
todos esperan ver son los protagonistas
de
Ataque a los titanes
la serie de manga y anime de hajime y se
llama es un éxito Planetario retrata a
una ciudad estilo medieval atacada sin
cesar por Gigantes caníbales el festival
de angulema abrió una exposición cuyas
entradas se agotaron de inmediato Fausto
fasulo es el comisario de la muestra
Ataque a los titanes
tiene algo que sedujo inmediatamente al
público tiene el poder de atraer
adolescentes y adultos porque es una
obra multifacética y abierta se puede
leer Esta obra con un prisma político o
como una obra de acción un relato de
suspenso o de espionaje un cuento post
medieval o una obra de guerra provoquen
los lectores muchas emociones melancolía
miedo palpitación en algunas escenas de
pelea y esa riqueza esa profundidad fue
lo que permitió a isayama tocar a tantos
lectores
[Música]
el terror es uno de los grandes géneros
de la cultura manga y por eso el
festival invitó al que apodan El maestro
japonés del terror el autor junji ito
para una exposición inmersiva llamada en
La Guarida del delirio Los la presenta
su comisario Estefan
gimendildológica se inspira en las
leyendas folclóricas en los años 80
cuando empieza la carrera de unjie hito
hay una ola de pánico en Japón debido a
leyendas urbanas y él va a inventarse su
propia mitología su propio folklore como
Tommy o como guía el tiburón con patas
tomiye que vemos aquí es su criatura
fetiche este personaje de mujer joven lo
va a convertir en el maestro de la
categoría de manga Jojo o sea para
chicas porque en Japón el género del
terror es para un público femenino por
otro lado está el manga para chicos
centrado en las peleas en la conquista
se trata de mangas sobre el deporte
historias de Samurai o de guerras
Galácticas
[Música]
el sector del manga es extremadamente
próspero es una economía que en Japón 95
mil millones de dólares anuales también
es un mundo muy masculino los mangaka
más exitosos son en su gran mayoría
hombres la autora
japonesai Busca en sus obras romper los
estereotipos sexistas que inundan las
páginas de manga
me interesa dibujar mujeres distintas
con modelos de vida diferentes mujeres
con hijos solteras esposas cuyo punto
común es que son libres de ser Quienes
son Espero que los personajes que dibujo
puedan ser modelos a seguir para los
lectores y las lectoras soy yo
no todos los mangakas son necesariamente
japoneses el festival de angulema fue
también una oportunidad para que los
fans descubrieran talentos emergentes
europeos como la española Ana Cristina
Sánchez autora del manga Sirius
[Música]
es el remate entre chicas es lo que a mí
me gusta dibujar pero el Yuri apenas
está despegando fue autodidacta Yo es
que me dedicaba a la autopublicación yo
hacía cómics y asistía eventos de manga
y anime en España entonces iba ponía con
un grupo un Stand y vamos vendiendo
nuestras cosas y en 2019 la editorial
planeta española
decidió iniciar un proyecto de revista
estilo japonés y estuvieron buscando
gente por el salón del manga y pues ahí
me contactaron y
y funcionó la cosa
después de Japón Francia es el segundo
país que más Lee manga en el mundo
Benito es un gran aficionado es el
fundador de meson otaku un medio
dedicado al mundo manga que además
organiza eventos para amantes de la
cultura pop japonesa y concursos de
cosplay el arte de encarnar a su
personaje favorito
el fenómeno cosplay consiste en vestirse
como nuestros Héroes favoritos O sea que
vamos a usar disfraces hechos a mano o
comprados y nos vamos a reunir entre
cosplayers antes no nos atrevíamos a
vestirnos con manga pero hoy en día lo
vemos por todas partes antes sólo
existían salones que llamamos
convenciones pero ahora Hay un montón de
eventos fiestas conciertos e incluso
reuniones entre colegas
en Francia uno de cada siete libros
vendidos es un mac
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenido al sejofenix me llamo kellys
dorigomo y Vento Calixto yo soy la
presentadora de Carrusel de las artes Y
tú tienes una ceremonia que presentará
en el circo Fénix adelante
[Aplausos]
el Mundial del circo del Mañana es el
evento más reconocido en el mundo y se
hace en la capital francesa bajo la
inmensa carpa del Circo Fénix son cuatro
días de una competencia y Show
deslumbrantes en el que se entregan
medallas de oro plata y bronce Alan es
su director
la competencia más importante para los
jóvenes artistas los productores del
mundo entero vienen a descubrir esos
nuevos talentos para ofrecerles
contratos en Cabaret en teatros o en
circos fue muy difícil anular el
festival tres años seguidos y decir a
los artistas que tenían años
preparándose que no se hacía el festival
así que esta edición es particular
[Música]
el circo sigue siendo muchos casos el
primer espectáculo que vemos cuando
Somos niños y es un arte que no ha
dejado de transformarse es lo más
increíble en Francia nos encanta el
circo hay más de 800 escuelas en el país
no todas son profesionales por supuesto
hay muchos centros para aficionados y
muchas escuelas para niños es una
disciplina que suscita gran pasión desde
hace siglos y ojalá que siga así
en París se juntan todas las escuelas
estilos y disciplinas del Circo moderno
desde la acrobacia los malabares la
magia hasta las técnicas más recientes
Es verdad que el circo se practica en
todo el mundo es un arte que ha viajado
por el planeta pero si tuviera que
destacar un país por su excelencia
técnica Yo diría que es china fueron los
chinos quienes inventaron la acrobacia
hace 5000 años en ese país hay 120
escuelas profesionales y 18 mil artistas
el festival del circo del mañana reúne a
artistas de 20 nacionalidades distintas
y nosotros fuimos a conocer a algunos de
ellos
México estuvo presente con un artista al
que no le da miedo hacer figuras a
varios metros del suelo es emmanueleros
especialista puro músculo de las cintas
aéreas y del mástil volante Me encantan
los dos Entonces yo un día estuve
pensando Por qué no hago una fusión de
del aparato y así es como se va a
presentar esta vez en el festival el
acto que es postraps una fusión entre lo
que es la cintas aéreas y el aire al
Paul aquí se verá
es mucha exigencia Física Pero donde yo
lo siento es en lo mental tengo que
estar muy bien agarrado sino ahí no
tengo ninguna otra oportunidad Entonces
sí hay como una un progreso de de
formación de entrenar todos los días
estar al menos yo tres cuatro horas
diarias entrenando comiendo bien
durmiendo bien pero yo creo que entreno
mucho la mente Yo siempre he dicho
volaré Tan Alto Como la vida Me lo me lo
deje yo amo estar arriba mis sueños
siempre ha sido volar más que hacer
Circo ha sido una pasión de estar en el
aire tener la adrenalina de poder
desconectarme de todo soy solo yo y el
aparato jugamos mucho con el peligro
pero que solo estando ahí arriba que
sabes que que uno se está agarrando muy
fuerte y que si sabes que por poquito
que dejes de dar pues puedes caer y
puede acabar tu vida artística no pero
no es una sensación muy muy linda
[Música]
por su parte los chicos de la compañía
internacional nicanor de Lía no despegan
del suelo pero les encanta desafiar la
gravedad y bailar en el escenario tres
de ellos se formaron en la ciudad
francesa de tu luz y vienen de Argentina
Uruguay y España la compañía somos el
director artístico y coreógrafo que se
llama justamente nicanor de Elías cinco
artistas en el escenario a los
espectáculos van de una sobre todo una
fusión entre danza y malabares o el
gestos cirquero y el movimiento corporal
[Música]
yo estoy bastante nervioso pero al mismo
tiempo es muy emocionante porque es una
vez en la vida y el circo Fénix es un
sitio bastante mítico es una sexta carpa
que vemos por la televisión que tiene
capacidad para 5.000 personas es algo
que normalmente no estamos acostumbrados
nosotros a hacer
[Música]
solo Este es un lugar donde la
espectacularidad de los números el circo
en sí mismo vuelve a algo que tiene
mucho que ver con su raíz y al mismo
tiempo el circo está pidiendo hace rato
abrir puertas de conexión con el mundo
de la Danza con el mundo del teatro ya
hace muchos años que la fusión permite
que la se resignifique y que se
reinvente el circo y eso me parece que
es importante porque permite a la gente
también seguir llegando al circo como en
su momento ya hace muchos años lo hizo
el siglo el circo del sol por ejemplo
llegar al circo desde otros lugares que
la gente quizás no está acostumbrada o
se sigue sorprendiendo
[Música]
hasta aquí Este programa especial que
tuvimos el agrado de presentarles desde
la carpa más grande de Europa el circo
Fénix de París Muchísimas gracias por
habernos acompañado y hasta una nueva
oportunidad
[Música]